you mean you see people get hit by
dildos that [ __ ] hurts yeah yo do you
remember hold up I know this one gets up
this one win - one second here go ahead
but just I hold up a hot second good you
can't say you can't see people get hit
my dildos man that's it hurts and then
just move on though you know you that
means so you know you've gotten here
with a dildo before no I was doing
plenty of videos - dudes getting hit
with dildos how's it but yeah I was
about to get to a real good one yeah but
you got a know firsthand that it hurts
no no no okay
not every nail does one but we don't
tell you man somebody did you ever may
hit with dildo that [ __ ] hurts anyways
what me and Taylor did bring like a
massive dildos like was supposed to be a
wholesome Secret Santa okay everyone you
know they were like there were strangers
there that we didn't know and it was
supposed to be like you know preferably
like gift like gift cards no no we're
like all right sex shop for sure we
brought one dildo and a set of anal
beads everyone else's gifts were like
super dope they're like nerf guns coffee
makers I was like oh wow and then we're
both like yep here goes oh no the
reaction was not like Oh bro there's one
person at that Secret Santa that keeps
stealing anything
keep it there's two people that really
want and they keep stealing it back from
each other I'll take it because you
don't want anything and I think it's
water fire or it's just one guy trying
to figure out how to steal it
he's like [ __ ] okay
he's got a really whack gift yeah he's
trying to figure out like how if I only
get two steals [ __ ]
oh you let me take that off your head
yeah because you don't want it and I did
so funny
I'll probably just worry gift it is so
funny I got a text the next morning from
my buddy he goes yo dude did you take
those anal beads with you and I was like
nah he just didn't respond to that but I
don't know why he asked me if I took
them with me because it
that's a weird quite you know true yeah
yeah it's not like you know who ended up
getting the anal beads
it was more like so so where they go
where they at where they at yo where
they had anyway there's this old video
this is a old internet [ __ ] okay this
video is [ __ ] up it was on e bombs
world of course it was a dude with like
a gigantic dildo I'm talking like like
to arm it was like a battle rope it was
like half a battle rope of dildo and
then no no yeah yeah yeah he held like
this and then it was another dude who
had a cat of nine tails know what that
is that medieval like it's like it's
like a whip it's got like nine ends to
it and it's got like like a sharp piece
of shrapnel on the end of it it's like
designed to [ __ ] you up okay these two
guys make like makeshift medieval like
shields and helmets out of cardboard and
they go to a playground and they fight
each other
cat and nine tails versatil though and
the dude like he's like he pulls the
dildo back and he swings it it cracks
that dude shield goes right over like
through to his face [ __ ] nails and it
looks so hard it [ __ ] him up so bad
damn that's dope yeah I want to see that
cannon ninetails versus a giant to watch
that video
that's prehistoric Internet that really
is that's some classic e bombs world
[ __ ] that sucks now dude I got too many
adults on there everything sucks now
yeah everything sucks yeah you know we
need like what's we need like the new
Internet like you know saying yeah like
that next thing that's like you know
there's no one should use this is bad
we're doing bad [ __ ] on here we got to
stop yeah that's is another
web isn't that like the next internet
now but that's just like selling drugs
like weird porn and so any like know
what it's gonna be yeah something that
like you don't want it you don't want
people knowing that you're on yeah yeah
yeah and when you hear about it on a
radio show you get freaked out because
people are gonna talk about it at work
and you're trying to figure out you
gonna actively deny it you're this thing
rotten dot-com oh no what is what's that
never heard of that yeah they like they
got it's like you know they got P like
helicopters going through people's head
yeah just a guess just to get yeah
I mean I've seen it I just let's made
you get the melon with the TPS reports
that's that's a callback baby that in
the biz is what we like to call a
callback
[Music]
[Music]